>> WE KNOW THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT WORK AND THE FIRST OF THOSE
THAT WORKED IS STEMMING THE FLOW
OF FIREARMS USED TO COMMIT
VIOLENT CRIMES.
>> WE RESPONDED IMMEDIATELY WHEN
WE SAW THOSE STUDENTS WITH
ASSAULT RIFLES THAT HIT OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES IN SUBURBAN
COUNTIES AND IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
BUT THE PROBLEM IN AMERICA IS
THE HANDGUN.
YET, THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
VICTIMS ARE BLACK, BROWN, AND
POOR.
WE HAVE IGNORED IT FOR FAR TOO
LONG.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK ABOUT ALL OF
THIS BRING IN OUR PANEL EARLY
TREY GOWDY FORMER CONGRESSMAN
FROM SOUTH CAROLINA.
HAROLD FORD JR. FORMER TEN IS HE
CONGRESSMAN AND CEO OF
EMPOWERMENT AND INCLUSION
CAPITAL AND AS MENTIONED BEFORE
JESSE WATTERS CO-HOST OF "THE
FIVE" AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK
"HOW I SAVED THE WORLD."
THIS IS A RARE EVENT, JESSE.
>> Jesse: IT IS.
I'M FEELING VERY SPECIAL AND I
WILL TRY NOT TO RUIN YOUR SHOW,
BRET.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
TREY, LET'S START WITH YOU ALL
THIS TALK OF GUNS AND GUN REFORM
AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW THE
WHITE HOUSE IS HAND LICK THIS
HOW PRESIDENT BIDEN IS TALKING
ABOUT THIS VIOLENCE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, BRET, GUN
PROSECUTIONS WENT DOWN UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
WITH VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN RIGHT
THERE BESIDE HIM.
I WANT YOUR VIEWERS TO FOCUS ON
THE GROUP THAT COB DISTANTLY
CALLS FOR GUN LAWS, GUN
PROSECUTIONS WENT DOWN WHEN THEY
WERE IN OFFICE.
SO WHAT WE KNOW IS DEFUNDING THE
POLICE DOESN'T WORK.
THIS BOND REFORM DOESN'T WORK.
THESE SO-CALLED PROGRESSIVE
PROSECUTORS DON'T WORK.
I HAVE GOT A REALLY CRAZY NOVEL
IDEA, HOW ABOUT ACTUALLY
ENFORCE -- YOU WOULD BE SHOCKED,
BRET, AT THE GUN LAWS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE.
BUT THEY DON'T DO ANY GOOD IF
THE FEDERAL PROSECUTORS AREN'T
ACTUALLY ENFORCING THEM.
SO HOW ABOUT WE START THERE?
>> Bret: HAROLD, THERE DOES SEEM
TO BE A POLITIC SOME DEMOCRATS
HOW THEY TALK ABOUT THIS AND
WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
MESSAGING ON THIS.
>> WELL, FIRST OFF, CONGRATS TO
JESSE ON THE BOOK AND THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS AS MUCH
OF A GAP AS WE THINK.
THE LEADER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS NEVER BEEN FOR
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
HE CONVENED A GROUP OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS TALK
CANDIDLY, TO TALK SERIOUSLY AND
BROADLY ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE.
THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE IN THE
LARGEST CITY OF THE COUNTRY THAT
HAS WITNESSED AND EXPERIENCED
SOME OF THE GREAT CRIME
REDUCTIONS OVER THE YEARS AND I
MIGHTED AS I WOULD AGREE WITH
TREY, GUN PROSECUTIONS SHOULD GO
BACK UP.
DURING THE -- EXCUSE ME DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION CRIME
AND VIOLENT CRIME RATES ARE DOWN
IN A LOT OF CITIES.
GOING UP NOW, CALLS FOR A
DIFFERENT SET OF REACTIONS.
I WAS ENCOURAGED BY THIS
MEETING.
I'M ENCOURAGED EACH BY THE
WILLNESS TO LISTEN TO SOME OF
THE BAIL REFORM CHANGES THAT
MUST HAPPEN.
SOME OF THEM WELL INTENTIONED
WANTED BAIL REFORM IT'S NOT
WORKING PUTTING CRIMINALS AND
VIOLENT PEOPLE OUT ON THE
STREET.
THERE HAS TO BE A BETTER WAY TO
ACHIEVE WHAT SOME OF THOSE
WANTED TO ACHIEVE WITH BAIL
REFORM TO ACHIEVE WITHOUT
ENDANGERING OUR COMMUNITIES AS
WE CERTAINLY HAVE.
FINALLY GO AFTER GHOST GUNS.
THEY'RE RIGHT ABOUT THAT AND I
HOPE THEY CONTINUE THAT PURSUIT.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, WE JUST SAW
THAT REPORT FROM MATT FINN THE
CHICAGO POLICE SUPERINTENDENT
TALKING ABOUT THE DISREGARD FOR
POLICE ON THE STREETS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THERE'S NO REGARD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S PRESENCE AT THESE
SCENES TO BRING THEM TO JUSTICE.
THEY WILL FIRE WEAPONS AT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR OOTHERS.
FOR WHAT APPEARS TO BE NO
APPARENT REASON.
>> Bret: JESSE, YOUR THOUGHTS?
?>> Jesse: THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN
TOO PERMISSIVE WHEN IT DOCUMENTS
ALL OF THESE PRECINCTS IN
LIBERAL AMERICA.
THE GUN ISSUE IS A DODGE.
WE HAVE THE STRICTEST GUN LAWS
IN THESE CITIES.
SO IT'S REALLY JUST ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT.
IF YOU ARE A GANG BANGER, BRET,
AND YOU GET POPPED FOR ILLEGAL
POSSESSION OF A FIREARM, YOU
COULD BE BOOKED OUT SAME DAY
BACK ON THE STREET, AND WHEN IT
IS TIME FOR SENTENCING, IF A
LIBERAL D.A. ONLY RECOMMENDS ONE
YEAR INSTEAD OF THE THREE TO
SEVEN AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
SAYS OKAY, LET'S JUST GO 10
DAYS, LIBERAL JUDGES IS GOING TO
SLICE IT IN HALF AND GIVE HIM
SIX MONTHS.
SO HE IS PAROLED IN SIX MONTHS
BACK OUT SQUEEZING THE TRIGGER
AND COMES INTO CONTACT WITH THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT'S UNDER
SIEGE BY LIBERAL ACTIVIST.
SO, UNLESS WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT INCARCERATION AND
PROSECUTION, I DON'T BELIEVE
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE WITH THE
DEMOCRATS.
JOE BIDEN IS DOING GREAT ON
COVID, BIG NUMBERS IN TERMS OF
APPROVAL, BUT WITH CRIME AND THE
BORDER, IS HE IN HIS 30'S.
AND YOU ADD CRITICAL RACE THEORY
TO THAT AND GAS PRICE THE TO
THAT.
EVENTUALLY COVID IS BECOME NOT
AN ISSUE ANYMORE.
HE HAS SOME STUFF THAT'S REALLY
JUST RIGHT THERE AT THE EDGE
WAITING TO TAKE HIM DOWN.
SO HE NEED TO FIX THIS QUICKLY
BUT I DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, TREY, SOME
MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS AT THE
BEGINNING AS WE WERE COVERING IT
HERE ON FOX SAID WE WERE BLOWING
IT UP OUT OF PROPORTION THAT
THIS WASN'T -- CRIME WASN'T AN
ISSUE ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
NOW THERE IS THIS MEETING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE, OBVIOUSLY IT'S
RISEN TO THE LEVEL POLITICALLY
HOW DOES THAT FALL, YOU KNOW, AS
WE GET CLOSER AND CLOSER TO
2022.
>> LOOK, THERE ARE LOT OF FOLKS
ON THE DEMOCRAT SIDE, HAROLD
FORD INCLUDED THAT ARE REALLY
SMART WHEN IT COMES TO POLITICS.
YOU LOOK AT JIM CLYBURN AND
OTHERS THEY WANT TO HOLD ONTO
THE HOUSE.
THEY KNOW IF THE ECONOMY IS OKAY
AND COVID IS OKAY.
PUBLIC SAFETY IS THE NUMBER ONE
FUNCTION OF GOVERNMENT.
SO, IF YOU CAN'T DO THAT, AND,
LOOK, LET'S BE FAIR, MOST OF
THIS CRIME STATE AND LOCAL.
BUT, WHEN YOU HAVE DEMOCRAT
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TALKING
ABOUT THE POLICE THE WAY RASHIDA
TLAIB AND OMAR AND AOC TALK
ABOUT THE COPS, THEN IT'S GONNA
TRICKLE INTO THE FEDERAL SYSTEM.
HE GET TO PICK U.S. ATTORNEYS.
LET'S PICK SOME THAT ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IN PUTTING PEOPLE,
VIOLENT OFFENDERS IN PRISON.
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT PLACE TO
START.
QUIT WITH THE PROGRESSIVE
PROSECUTORS, PICK U.S. ATTORNEYS
THAT ACTUALLY BELIEVE IN
ENFORCING GUN LAWS.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT, PANEL, WE
WILL SEE YOU AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE SHOW.
WE WILL D